yes well this is you with Rihanna
guys who wouldn't
I like that that is so not it's not even
subtle it's just like hello
I mean I remember because I I've known
her for a very long time and I just
remember seeing because every time I
mean especially in that show she
obviously has magnificent lungs yes she
um you know I just went up to I was like
you look amazing then every time she was
like you've got to be on boob watch so I
just because you know it's definitely
something you have to be careful but I
was I was being a good friend guys but
evidence I feel like you're very happy
to have your picture taken
oh really
yeah you're entirely wrong
because I see there's a picture someone
posted it on Twitter of of you and
there's a fence in it and I don't know
who's being protected it's in it there's
a fence in it
[Laughter]
that's the reading music festival
that would have been amazing that was me
and my 54 year old best mate and 90 000
teenagers
oh I can't tell you and I thought this
is nice this is nice and then well two
things happened first of all I got into
the mosh pit well with the architect
monkeys were playing and I thought oh
I'm going to die
I was like all crushed in we've been
moved up and down by people thinking oh
now's when I die
I I always wondered and I thought it
would probably be young but I didn't I
didn't picture this you know and then I
thought we all walked back you know with
the 90 000 teenagers who are all high on
those and I thought this is really quite
nice and then someone shot on someone's
tent and then someone
you know and then some it would just and
then the toilets overflowed and I had to
use those little piss things you know
because
she had a little she things and of
course it's absolutely hilarious because
you peed on it and it's supposed to go
down the street and I instead what it
does is take all of the weight and push
it into your body
it's very efficient thing if you want to
cover yourself in weave or whatever
medical reason you might have psoriasis
or something then it would work it would
be good you should have been a doctor
Emma Thompson
you are a waster than an actress wasted
oh it was hell it was hell I'm never
going again I love that what people
would have thought when they're high on
whatever at reading Festival running
into be like
tragic
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]